>>> THERE IS MORE BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF THE
U.S. FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION HAS VOTED TO
RECOMMEND PFIZER'S COVID VACCINE
FOR CHILDREN AGES 5 TO 11 UNDER
EMERGENCY USE.
THE PANEL SUPPORTS THE DOSAGE
THAT'S ONE-THIRD OF WHAT IS
GIVEN TO THOSE OVER THE AGE OF
12 IN TWO SHOTS, THREE WEEKS
APART.
PFIZER SAYS ITS VACCINE FOR
CHILDREN, AGES 5 TO 11 IS 90%
EFFECTIVE AGAINST SYMPTOMATIC
COVID.
MEMBERS OF THE FDA COMMITTEE
AGREED THE BENEFITS APPEAR TO
OUTWEIGH THE RISK BUT THEY HAD
SOME CONCERNS INCLUDING WHETHER
STATES WOULD NOW MANDATE THE
VACCINE FOR CHILDREN TO GO TO
SCHOOL AFTER A FEW MORE STEPS
ABOUT 28 MILLION CHILDREN AS
YOUNG AS 5 COULD GET THE VACCINE
AS EARLY AS NEXT WEEK.
JOINING US NOW, DR. PETER HOTEZ,
AUTHOR OF PREVENTING THE NEXT
PANDEMIC, VACCINE DIPLOMACY IN A
TIME OF ANTI-SCIENCE.
AND CNN MEDICAL ANALYST, DR.
LEANA WEN, FORMER BALTIMORE
HEALTH COMMISSIONER AND AUTHOR
OF LIFELINES, A DOCTOR'S JOURNEY
IF THE FIGHT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
IN PART, BECAUSE THE CDC
PRESENTED EVIDENCE THAT MANY
MORE CHILDREN HAVE COVID-19
ANTIBODIES THAN PREVIOUSLY
THOUGHT.
I AM CURIOUS, AS TO WHAT YOU
THINK IF A CHILD BETWEEN 5 AND
11 YEARS OLD HAS COVID
ANTIBODIES DO YOU THINK THEY
NEED BOTH DOSES OF PFIZER'S
VACCINE?
>> WELL FIRST OF ALL, ANDERSON,
IT'S VERY TOUGH TO KNOW FOR
CERTAIN IF A CHILD HAS PREVIOUS
COVID INFECTION OR NOT.
AND -- AND SIMPLY, MEASURING
ANTIBODIES IS -- IS VARIABLE AND
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW DURABLE THAT
PROTECTION IS.
BUT HERE'S -- HERE'S THE --
HERE'S -- HERE'S WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER.
WE SAW THE DEVASTATION AMONG
PEDIATRIC POPULATIONS THIS
SUMMER BECAUSE OF THE DELTA
VARIANT.
WE SAW UNPRECEDENTED NUMBERS OF
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE I
CAN REMEMBER, PEDIATRIC
INTENSIVE CARE UNITS
OVERWHELMED.
SO, WE SAW THIS FIVEFOLD
INCREASE OVER LATER IN THE
SUMMER.
UM, AMONG PEDIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATIONS HERE IN THE
SOUTH.
8,300 HOSPITALIZATIONS,
ALTOGETHER, FOR CHILDREN.
ABOUT HALF.
YOUNG CHILDREN 5 TO 11 HALF WITH
THAT MULTISYSTEM INFLAMMATORY
SYNDROME OF -- OF -- OF
CHILDHOOD WHICH IS VERY SEVERE.
100 DEATHS BETWEEN THE AGES OF 5
TO 11 AND ABOUT 14% OF THE -- OF
THE KIDS HAVING LONG-COVID
SYMPTOMS LASTING MORE THAN 15
MONTHS.
BOTTOM LINE, WE LEARNED THIS
SUMMER THAT COVID-19'S A VERY
BAD ACTOR IN THE CHILDREN 5 TO
11 AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED IT.
>> DR. WEN, I MENTIONED ANOTHER
POINT OF DISCUSSION TODAY IS
MANDATES AND WHETHER EMERGENCY
USE AUTHORIZATION FOR PFIZER'S
KID VACCINE IS GOING TO LEAD TO
MORE MANDATES.
DO YOU THINK THAT SHOULD HAPPEN?
OR SHOULD PARENTS WITH KIDS
BETWEEN 5 AND 11 BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE TO GET THEIR CHILD
VACCINATED OR NOT?
>> I THINK IT'S WAY TOO EARLY
FOR US TO BE TALKING ABOUT
MARIANNA DATES IN THIS AGE
GROUP.
SO FAR, WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT
STUDY BUT THE STUDY BY PFIZER IS
JUST OVER 2,000 KIDS.
I THINK THE RIGHT NEXT STEP IS
TO HAVE THE PARENTS WHO REALLY
WANT TO GET THEIR KIDS
VACCINATED TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
THAT.
THERE ARE LOTS OF PARENTS WHO
ARE LIVING IN AREAS THAT ARE NOT
REQUIRING MASKS IN SCHOOLS.
WHERE THEIR -- THEIR KIDS ARE
BEING EXPOSED TO A LOT OF RISK
FACTORS AND THEIR KIDS HAVE
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
INCLUDING ASTHMA AND OBESITY
THAT PREDISPOSE THEM TO SEVERE
OUTCOMES FROM COVID-19 IF THEY
WERE TO HAVE IT.
SO I THINK THOSE PARENTS THAT
ARE EAGER TO GET THEIR KIDS
VACCINATED, GET VACCINATED.
LET'S COLLECT SOME MORE
INFORMATION AND THEN IF WE HAVE
MORE INFORMATION INCLUDE ABOUT
WHAT IT IS THAT VACCINES CAN
REPLACE.
FOR EXAMPLE, CAN VACCINES
REPLACE A NEED FOR MASKS IN
SCHOOLS?
CAN VACCINES HELP TO PREVENT
OUTBREAKS AND THEN STOP THE NEED
FOR QUARANTINING AND HAVING KIDS
NOT BE IN SCHOOL?
THEN MAYBE THEN, WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT MANDATES BUT
WE ARE A LONG WAY OFF FROM THAT.
>> DR. HOTEZ, I MEAN, THE
ADVISERS ALSO DISCUSSED
MYOCARDITIS, WHICH IS
INFLAMMATION OF THE HEART MUSCLE
AND ANOTHER -- A RARE SIDE
EFFECT OF THE PFIZER AND MODERNA
VACCINE.
AS A PEDIATRICIAN, HOW CONCERNED
ARE YOU ABOUT MYOCARDITIS AS A
VACCINE SIDE EFFECT IN 5 TO 11?
>> WELL, IT'S SOMETHING WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO WATCH.
SO, IN THE -- WHAT THE CONCERN
WAS IN THE 12 TO 17-YEAR-OLDS,
WE DID SEE A BUMP IN RATES BUT
IT IS STILL AN EXTREMELY RARE
EVENT BETWEEN 4 AND 10 PER
100,000.
SO, IT'S -- IT'S STILL EXTREMELY
UNCOMMON.
>> FOUR AND TEN TEENAGERS PER
100,000 GOT AN INFLAMMATION?
>> THAT -- THAT'S RIGHT.
SO, IT'S AN EXTREMELY RARE
EVENT.
I MEAN, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ONE
IN 10,000, ON AVERAGE.
AND SO, THAT'S -- THAT'S QUITE
UNCOMMON.
AND ALMOST ALL OF THOSE DID
QUITE WELL AND -- AND HAD
SPONTANEOUS RESOLUTION.
SOMETIMES, REQUIRING
HOSPITALIZATION.
SO, BUT THE -- BUT THE KEY POINT
TO REMEMBER, ANDERSON, IS THAT
THE RATE OF MYOCARDITIS AND
OTHER CARDIAC SEQUELLE FROM THE
VIRUS, IS POSSIBLY AS HIGH AS
450 PER -- PER MILLION.
SO, NOT ONLY THAT, WE ARE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT OTHER
CARDIOVASCULAR CONSEQUENCES.
THROMBOTIC EVENTS, STROKES.
SO, ALL OF THAT HAS TO BE KEPT
IN MIND, AS WELL.
SO, MYOCARDITIS IS STILL AN
EXTREMELY RARE EVENT.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO WATCH, AND AS
DR. WEN POINTS OUT, THIS STUDY
THAT -- THAT THE BRIDGING STUDY
THAT MOVE FORWARD ON THE
AUTHORIZATION HAD ONLY ABOUT
2,000 KIDS.
SO, WE ARE GOING TO COLLECT A
LOT MORE INFORMATION HOPEFULLY
IN THE COMING MONTHS.
>> DR. WEN, ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS,
ALMOST 118,000 CHILDREN TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID LAST WEEK.
AS MUCH AS THE COUNTRY MOVES
INTO COLDER MONTHS, COLD OR FLU
SEASON, HOW BIG OF A DIFFERENCE
WILL GETTING YOUNGER -- THE
YOUNGER POPULATION VACCINATED,
HOW MUCH DIFFERENCE WILL THAT
ACTUALLY MAKE?
>> I THINK IT WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF WHERE
COVID-19 GOES BECAUSE WE COULD
HAVE 28 MILLION MORE AMERICANS
WHO ARE NOW ELIGIBLE TO BE
VACCINATED.
BUT I THINK IT WILL MAKE THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE LIVES OF PARENTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN.
KIDS HAVE MISSED OUT ON SO MUCH.
THEY'VE BEEN PULLED OUT OF
SPORTS.
THEY MISSED OUT ON
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES.
MAYBE, THEY STOPPED HAVING
SLEEPOVERS AND GOING TO INDOOR
BIRTHDAY PARTIES.
THEY CAN NOW RESUME MANY OF
THESE THINGS ONCE THEY ARE
VACCINATED.
ALSO, WE ARE COMING INTO HOLIDAY
SEASON AND IF WE ARE ABLE TO GET
THE VACCINE AUTHORIZED BY THE
FDA, RECOMMENDED BY THE CDC BY
NEXT WEEK, THEN KIDS COULD BE
FULLY VACCINATED BY THE TIME
THAT CHRISTMAS AND NEW YEAR'S,
WINTER HOLIDAYS COME AROUND.
I THINK THAT WILL MAKE A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE.
AND FOR PARENTS, TOO.
PARENTS HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH SO
MUCH CAUTION BECAUSE OF THEIR
KIDS, WORRIED ABOUT TRAVEL,
WORRIED ABOUT OCCUPATIONAL
EXPOSURE.
IT WILL ALLOW PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN TO RETURN TO A LARGE
PORTION OF THEIR PRE-PANDEMIC
NORMAL.
>> DR. HOTEZ, I WANT TO CHANGE
TOPICS QUICKLY.
ASK YOU ABOUT COMMENTS MADE BY
FORMER TRUMP CORONAVIRUS
COORDINATOR, DR. DEBORAH BIRX TO
A CONGRESSIONAL SUBCOMMITTEE
WHEN INTERVIEWED EARLIER THIS
MONTH ABOUT THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION'S HANDLING OF THE
VIRUS, SHE SAID THE 2020
CAMPAIGN, QUOTE, TOOK PEOPLE'S
TIME AWAY FROM AND DISTRACTED
THEM AWAY FROM THE PANDEMIC.
DR. BIRX ALSO SAID SHE BELIEVES
MORE THAN 130,000 AMERICAN LIVES
COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED IF MORE
MITIGATION MEASURES HAD BEEN PUT
IN EFFECT.
I MEAN, WHICH IS PRETTY STUNNING
STATEMENT.
130,000 NEEDLESS DEATHS.
I AM WONDERING WHAT YOUR
REACTION WAS TO THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WHEN I FIRST
HEARD IT, MY FIRST THOUGHT WAS,
YOU KNOW, WHAT THE PRESIDENT --
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE WEST WING, AND
THE OVAL OFFICE DID WAS FAR MORE
THAN BE DISTRACTED BECAUSE OF
THE CAMPAIGN.
THEY ACTIVELY UNDERMINED
COVID-19 EFFORTS.
THEY LAUNCHED A HORRIFIC
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN IN THE
SPRING AND SUMMER OF 2020.
CLAIMING COVID WAS A HOAX.
NOTHING MORE THAN THE FLU.
SPECTACULARIZING THE BENEFITS OF
HIGH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
SAYING HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS WERE
JUST CATCHUP AND ELECTIVE
SURGERIES AND THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY DAMAGING AND CAUSED A
LOT OF LOSS OF LIFE,
DISCREDITING MASKS.
AND THEN, IN PARALLEL, WHAT THEY
DID WAS THEY ULTIMATELY REFUSED
TO LAUNCH A NATIONAL PROGRAM TO
CONTROL COVID-19.
WHAT THEY DID, INSTEAD, WAS
LEAVE IT TO THE STATES AND THEY
NEVER PUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OUT IN FRONT AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT WERE THE
STATES DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO DO
THIS.
AND -- AND